la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restent en
discussion du projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable la parole est à
Monsieur Didier mandelier rapporteur
pour le Sénat de la commission mixte
paritaire et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
il y a plus de 3 mois notre assemblée
adoptée à la quasialimité le projet
Loire relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable en
complétant largement le texte du
Gouvernement
après la lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
une commission mixte paritaire
conclusive leur est venue de transformer
l'essai
le chemin que nous avons parcouru depuis
le temps dernier n'a pas été sans écueil
et sans difficulté notamment dans cette
hémicycle mais erreurs du bilan je pense
pouvoir dire que cet effort collectif
n'a pas été 20 j'ose le dire le texte
qui vous est soumis aujourd'hui fait
largement teneur à notre travail à votre
travail avant de présenter les
évolutions notables à portées par la CMP
j'aimerais appeler les objectifs qui ont
été ceux de la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable au nom de laquelle
je m'exprime aujourd'hui
le renforcement de la planification
territoriale duration de la concertation
autour des projets afin de passer d'une
logique descendante à une approche
ascendante nous avions ainsi institué un
dispositif global de planification
territoriale du déploiement des énergies
renouvelables mettant les élus locaux
auprès desquels les mers à la manoeuvre
pour définir les zones d'accélération
des énergies renouvelables dans la même
logique nous avions proposé une
planification spatiale dédiée à l'éolien
en mer notamment avec le principe d'une
localisation prioritaire des parcs
éoliens au sein de la zone économique
exclusive soit à plus de 22 km du rivage
afin d'améliorer l'acceptabilité des
projets négociation qui ont été réalisés
en direct dans cette hémicycle après une
suspension de séance en deux la
simplification des procédures
applicables au projet ENR pour réduire
les délais de déploiement des projets
des mesures destinées à simplifier le
cadre des autorisations administratives
avaient été introduites nous avions
également mis en place un fonds de
garantie pour couvrir les risques
contentieux faisant sur les porteurs de
projets
on prend la libération de surface
artificialisée nous avions renforcer la
couverture en énergie solaire des
bâtiments non résidentiels et faciliter
l'installation d'ouvrage renouvelables
sur les bâtiments
4 enfin la sécurisation juridique des
dispositions du projet de loi par
exemple en s'assurant que l'ensemble des
énergies renouvelables soient bien
incluses dans le champ du texte qui
n'était pas le cas à l'origine force et
de constater que le texte issu des
négociations que nous examinons
aujourd'hui conforte largement ses axes
de réflexion la grande majorité de nos
propositions ont été conservées par
l'Assemblée nationale de la CMP
celle-ci a permis des compromis
confortant les positions exprimées par
le Sénat ainsi sur les 108 articles du
texte final 39 ont été introduits par
notre chambre quelques suppressions
d'articles et dispositions votées par le
Sénat sont certes à déplorés comme c'est
toujours le cas dans une CMP équilibrée
je note toutefois que la balance penche
très nettement notre faveur
sur le fond la version finale du texte
est plus ambitieuse que le projet qui
nous était soumis il y a quelques mois
le texte offre d'une part plus de
leviers d'accélération pour le
développement des énergies renouvelables
il donne d'autre part des garanties qui
favoriseront une appropriation
territoriale des projets le dispositif
de planification territoriale dont la
version qui vous est proposée
aujourd'hui répond tout particulièrement
à cette double exigence d'accélération
du déploiement et d'appropriation
territoriale une négociation ont permis
à notre initiative de donner plus de
corps aux zones d'accélération qui
seront identifiées localement en y
prévoyant des mesures de simplification
procédurale spécifique
les négociations nous ont également
permis de pérenniser plusieurs mesures
de simplification administratives visant
à accélérer l'instruction des projets
d'énergie renouvelables nous avons aussi
pu rétablir l'article 5 dans une version
très proche de celle adoptée par le
Sénat qui nous permettra aux côtés du
fond de garantie créateur à notre
initiative de limiter le risque
contentieux
par ailleurs la Commission mix paritaire
nous a permis de rétablir des apports
importants qui contribueront à la
solarisation des toitures les bâtiments
non résidentiels existants de plus de
500 mètres carrés devront par exemple
être couverts par un dispositif de
production d'énergie solaire ou un
dispositif végétalisé avant 2028 enfin
les bâtiments neufs devront être prêts à
accueillir des énergies renouvelables et
des collectivités collectivités
territoriales pourront déroger aux
règles d'urbanisme pour les
installations en toiture
en guise de conclusion il me reste à
remercier les présidents de commission
pour leur implication tout au long de
travaux
le Sophie est Jean-François le
rapporteur Patrick Chauvet ainsi que
l'ensemble des groupes pour le travail
collectif qui nous a permis d'améliorer
le texte qui nous était proposé mais
remercions vont également aux
administrateurs du Sénat et au
rapporteur de l'Assemblée nationale pour
la qualité des échanges préparatoires à
la commission mix paritaire et à vous
madame la ministre pour le sens du
dialogue dont vous avez su faire preuve
dès l'origine et tout au long de
l'examen de ce texte formons le veut que
la loi de programmation quinquennale que
nous aurons examiné courant 2023 nous
donne un nouveau l'occasion de vrai
collectivement à l'atteinte de nos
objectifs climatiques et énergétiques
Agnès Panine ministre de la transition
énergétique
madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente de commission
monsieur le président de commission
chers Sophie cher Jean-François
messieurs les rapporteurs chers Didier
cher Patrick mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le projet de loi sur
l'accélération de la production des
énergies renouvelables touche à sa fin
au Sénat la même où il a commencé ce
projet de loi se veut une réponse à
trois chiffres que je vous avais exposé
trois données qui soulignent la
nécessité d'agir 3 données qui
démontrent à quel point notre pays se
trouve à un tournant historique
deux tiers c'est la part d'énergie
fossile dans notre consommation finale
d'énergie deux tiers de gaz de fioul de
carburant doudou nous ne pouvons
aujourd'hui pas nous passer pour notre
industrie pour nous déplacer et pour
nous chauffer deux tiers d'énergie
fossile importée au détriment de notre
balance commerciale comme de notre
souveraineté
2035 c'est la date à laquelle 26 de nos
56 réacteurs nucléaires arriveront en
termes de 50 années d'exploitation
tous devront alors passer le cap d'un
contrôle de sûreté approfondi pour être
prolongé 10 années de plus vous le savez
en matière énergétique 2035 c'est demain
60% c'est selon RTE la proportion
d'électricité que nous devons produire
en plus à l'horizon 2050 pour répondre à
nos besoins croissants d'électrification
pour l'industrie les transports et les
bâtiments si nous voulons devenir le
premier pays industriel au monde à
sortir des énergies fossiles et à
atteindre la neutralité carbone si nous
voulons devenir enfin maître de notre
destin énergétique nous ne pourrons nous
passer d'aucune énergie décarbonée
qu'elle soit nucléaire ou renouvelable
tant la marche à franchir et haute nous
devons accélérer accélérer car nous
sommes le pays européen qui n'a pas
atteint ses objectifs de déploiement des
énergies renouvelables accélérer car
face aux dérèglement climatiques tous
les scientifiques nous le disent nos
prochains objectifs seront encore plus
ambitieux
voici l'enjeu de ce texte lever tous les
verrous qui retardent le déploiement des
projets d'énergie renouvelables ni plus
ni moins il ne s'agit ni d'allouer des
moyens financiers déjà prévus dans le
projet de loi de finances ni d'anticiper
la future programmation sur l'énergie et
le climat qui nous le savons
mathématiquement conduira plus de
production d'énergie renouvelable pour
répondre à cette ambition d'accélération
j'avais pris un engagement devant vous
celui de co-construire ce texte de le
co-construire avec tous ceux qui veulent
agir pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et la compétitivité de nos
entreprises tous ceux qui souhaitent
défendre l'indépendance industrielle
énergétique et donc politique de notre
pays tous ceux enfin qui veulent lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique cette
méthode inédite à définir les grands
équilibres de ce texte construit ses
grands apports de manière consensuelle
et conduit à sa large adoption au sein
de votre chambre
je tiens à souligner la qualité des
échanges et du travail conduit par les
rapporteurs Didier mantelli et Patrick
Chauvet et par les présidents de
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire et la
présidente des affaires de la commission
des affaires économiques Jean-François
Longeot et Sophie prima je souhaite
également remercier l'ensemble des
responsables de textes dans chaque
groupe avec qui j'ai eu des échanges
continuent nourris et c'est normal
exigeant permettez-moi maintenant de
prendre quelques instants pour souligner
les avancées majeures qui ont permis nos
débats sur la planification d'abord
c'était une demande des territoires
portés par le Sénat pour la première
fois nous créons un système de
planification qui met les élus locaux au
centre du jeu qui leur fait confiance la
commission mixte paritaire a permis de
préciser le dispositif en simplifiant le
système et en conférant au comité
régionaux de l'énergie un rôle de vigie
sur les zones d'accélération et
d'exclusion regarde des futurs objectifs
de la programmation plus réelle
régionalisée et je le rappelle
pas de zone d'accélération pas de zone
d'exclusion c'est un levier offert aux
élus pour aménager leur territoire en
décidant des zones où ils vont en
priorité développer les projets
d'énergie renouvelables les élus locaux
proposent et ont le dernier mot sur les
zonage aucune commune ne pourra se faire
imposer une zone d'accélération sur son
territoire mais la somme de ces zones
doit permettre d'être à la hauteur des
ambitions de la production de la
production de la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie deuxième sujet la
grivoltaïsme c'est une mesure issue
d'une proposition de loi largement
adoptée par le Sénat je tiens à saluer
l'auteur Jean-Pierre de Cole et le
rapporteur Franck Menonville mais aussi
Jean-François Longeau Jean-Pierre Maugat
et l'ensemble des sénateurs qui ont
travaillé sur ce sujet de nombreux mois
notre objectif je les maintes fois
répéter et de concilier souveraineté
alimentaire et souveraineté énergétique
il y avait que le texte que vous votez
aujourd'hui je crois pouvoir dire que
nous sommes à la hauteur de l'enjeu pour
la première fois nous donnons en une
définition de la grivevoltaïsme avec des
conditions un encadrement qui
garantissent la compatibilité des
activités agricoles avec les activités
énergétiques et le bénéfice des
activités énergétiques pour les
activités agricoles le texte vient
également encadrer l'installation de
nouveaux voltaïques sur sol agricole
afin qu'aucune terre fertile ne soit
sacrifiée et qu'aucune forêt ne soit
inutilement défricher en effet c'est le
troisième sujet nous favorisons
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables dans les zones déjà
artificialisées en matière d'énergie
renouvelable les bâtiments constituent
une priorité de mesure importante avec
déjà été prise dans la loi climat
résilience nous avons rehaussé les
objectifs de développement de panneaux
photovoltaïques sur les bâtiments neufs
et lourdement rénové surtout la
commission mixte paritaire a renforcé
l'ambition du texte sur les bâtiments
existants elle a introduit en effet une
obligation de couverture des bâtiments
non résidentiels ayant une emprise au
sol au moins égal à 500 mètres carrés
soit d'un procédé de production
d'énergie renouvelable soit d'un système
de végétalisation je salue cette avancée
qui était attendue par plusieurs groupes
par ailleurs nous avons également
apporté des facilités pour implanter des
projets d'énergie renouvelables sur tous
les délaissés routiers ferroviaires
fluvio c'est une avancée massive et
inédite nous avons enfin retenu un seuil
obligatoire pour l'installation de
Brière sur parking de 1500 mètres carrés
ce qui va considérablement augmenter le
nombre de parking ayant l'obligation
d'installer des ombrières ses avancées
elles n'étaient pas écrites c'est grâce
à vos propositions et à nos échanges que
nous avons augmenté notre ambition autre
sujet celui du partage de la valeur
c'est un amor un apport majeur de ce
texte il doit permettre que les
habitants et les communes tirent
directement partie des retombées des
projets d'énergie renouvelables et
qu'ils soient associés à leur réussite
et je remercie la présidente Sophie
prima il aura porteur Patrick Chauvet
qui ont particulièrement travaillé sur
ce sujet la création d'un front de
financement d'actions locales pour les
collectivités d'un second Didier à la
biodiversité et si j'ose au l'ouverture
d'un financement participatif des
habitants au projet sur leur territoire
sont des apports positifs que nous
soutenons et car nous avons entendu
certaines craintes nous avons complété
ces dispositifs en permettant aux
collectivités locales de soutenir
directement leur habitant et notamment
les ménages en précarité énergétique
enfin j'aimerais jouis que ce texte
facilite le développement des énergies
renouvelables dans les territoires
d'outre-mer ce texte n'aurait pas été
complet sans ces dispositions les
énergies renouvelables étant
stratégiques pour l’autonomie
énergétique de ces territoires qui sont
mal interconnectés et alors que beaucoup
connaissent des difficultés et des
dépendances à des énergies fossiles je
tiens à remercier les députés des
outre-mer et les sénateurs et plus
largement des zones d'un interconnectées
pour le travail collectif mené sur ces
sujets mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nous avons démontré que les
chemins pour bâtir des compromis au
service de notre pays existent il s'agit
maintenant de les emprunter de les
emprunter pour agir et lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique pour construire
notre indépendance énergétique pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Françaises et des Français et pour
défendre la compétitivité de nos
entreprises je vous remercie merci même
la ministre alors je rappelle qu'en
application de l'article 42 alinéa 12 du
règlement le Sénat examinant après
l'Assemblée nationale le texte élaboré
par la commission mixte paritaire il se
prononce par un seul vote sur l'ensemble
de ce texte en ne retenant que les
amendements présentés ou acceptés par le
gouvernement en conséquence le vote sur
les amendements et sur les articles et
réserver nous passons donc à la des
amendements du Gouvernement avant d'en
venir aux explications de votre des
groupes madame la ministre si vous
voulez bien
accepter de présenter l'ensemble de
voilà vos amendements merci beaucoup ce
sont des amendements rédactionnels ou de
coordination comme il arrive souvent
dans ce type de texte qui vont préciser
des références juridiques changer ici un
mot là assurer la bonne référence donc
18 amendements mais qui apportent
surtout une renforcement de la tenue
juridique de ce texte
merci beaucoup la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est un avis favorable sur chacun de
ses amendements qui ont été vus ce matin
en commission il s'agit effectivement
d'amendement rédactionnel après pour
pour l'essentiel après passage en CMP
alors nous allons passer donc aux
explications
à raison
vous avez un temps de parole
l'explication de votre non non non
mais vous allez avoir 5 minutes donc
nous allons passer donc aux explications
de votre des groupes à raison d'un
orateur par groupe et la parole est à
Madame Nadège avait pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 5
minutes
[Musique]
ce que nous faisons il y a deux semaines
toujours réunies pendant près de 5
heures en commission mixte paritaire
avec nos collègues députés nous
parvenions à un compromis sur le sujet
de la loi relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelables les
conclusions que nous examinons
aujourd'hui sont le fruit d'un travail
parlementaire de plusieurs mois d'une
construction transpartisane alors que
nous nous apprêtons à les adopter je
veux saluer une nouvelle fois votre
travail messieurs et Madame les
rapporteurs et votre écoute votre
méthode de co-construction Madame le
Ministre et également remercier toutes
les équipes qui ont travaillé à la
rédaction afin d'accélérer nos
actionnons dans ce texte tous les
leviers disponibles en agissant sur la
simplification des procédures je les
fais ok précédemment en libérant du
foncier et en partageant la valeur
productive produite les discussions au
cours de la CMP auront beaucoup porté
sur la planification territoriale du
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
et nous avons abouti des zones
d'accélération non inclusive pourront
être identifiées et le conseil municipal
gardera un rôle clé sur l'agrerie
voltaïsme ensuite intégrer au Sénat en
première lecture une définition est
désormais apportée un encadrement est
fixé un nouvel outil au service des
agriculteurs et des agriculteurs sans
que la production d'électricité Vienne
concurrencer la production alimentaire
avec des précisions aussi sur la
comptabilité la compatibilité entre
l'agrivoltaïsme et les aides de la
politique agricole à plusieurs endroits
du texte nous venons favoriser
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables dans les zones déjà
artificialisées de même que sur les
délaissés routiers et ferroviaires nous
intégrons également dans la loi un seuil
obligatoire pour l'installation
d'ombrière sur les parkings de 1500
mètres carrés
le partage de la valeur figure aussi
parmi les apports majeurs de ce texte la
création d'une contribution territoriale
permettra notamment de financer des
projets des communes et de leur
groupement en faveur de la transition
énergétique telle que la rénovation
énergétique et les filles qu'à citer et
la mobilité propre je me fais ici
également des avancées sur l'éolien pour
aruturer un raccordement effectif des
éoliennes en mer la CMP a autorisé
l'implantation d'ouvrage de transport
d'électricité par des gorrogation à la
loi littorale le Sénat a été là encore
entendu dans sa volonté de mieux
associer les élus locaux à cette
dérogation de même qu'il a été suivi
pour ce qui concerne la généralisation
du dispositif de planification
spécifique au projet éolien en mer à
l'ensemble des façades maritimes enfin
concernant le rôle des ABS une voie
médiane à là encore été empruntée il est
désormais prévu dans la loi que les ABS
n'ont plus une la commission la
protection du patrimoine mais aussi la
transition énergétique une circulaire
viendra préciser cela et nous y serons
attentifs je crois par conséquent que
les équilibres ont été respectés par le
projet de loi les sénateurs de mon
groupe RDPI le voteront évidemment et
avec ce texte qui aura bientôt force de
loi la France fera mieux l'enjeu en
premier je le rappelle et celui de la
défense de notre souveraineté et de
notre indépendance future je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Hervé gilet pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain également pour 5 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre les sénateurs du groupe
socialiste écologique et républicains
s'engagent depuis plusieurs années sur
l'urgence à passer d'une écologie de
principes à une écologie d'action avec
ce texte nous touchons du bout du doigt
notre objectif est une majorité arrive
enfin une volonté commune l'accélération
du déploiement des énergies
renouvelables ceci étant nous continuons
à nous interroger sur le calendrier de
programmation des projets accélération
des énergies renouvelables et nucléaires
pour finir sur une loi de programmation
énergique climat qui cristallisera le
choix de notre mix énergétique bref nous
mettons la charrue avant les boeufs pour
autant c'est parce que la France a été
le seul pays de l'Union européenne avoir
manqué son objectif de production des
énergies renouvelables en 2020 que le
groupe socialiste a agi en
responsabilité pour améliorer autant que
possible ce texte nécessaire afin de
trouver une issue favorable il conserve
son objectif initial d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables tout en tenant
compte du rôle central des collectivités
territoriales et de la nécessaire
préservation de la biodiversité en effet
plusieurs améliorations sont notables
premièrement la CMP est revenue sur la
rédaction de l'article 4 en
réintroduisant le fait que les projets
de NR qui pourront bénéficier de manière
automatique de la raison impérative
d'intérêt publics majeurs devront
répondre à des conditions définies par
décret en Conseil d'État ce que nous
considérons comme une mesure de
protection
deuxièmement elle supprime la
modification de la répartition de la
taxe sur l'éolien en mer entre les
communes sur la base de la population
dite DGF c'est à dire en majorant la
population d'un habitant par résidence
secondaire c'était quand même assez
déstabilisant par après avoir certaines
communes du littoral concernant
l'accélération du développement de
l'énergie solaire thermique et
photovoltaïque depuis le début d'examen
de ce texte notre groupe a privilégié le
développement d'énergie solaire sur le
bâti existant plutôt qu'une augmentation
de l'artificialisation
le texte va au-delà de ce qui était
initialement proposé par le projet de
loi initial c'est donc un grand pas nous
avons défendu à un encadrement des
nouvelles dérogations la loi littorale
et à la loi montagne pour éviter une
action du mitage des territoires avec un
risque accru de Roger par les habitants
des projets sur ses espaces protégés
aussi le compromis trouvé en CMP qui
permet de recueillir la vie des
associations représentatives des
collectivités territoriales concernées à
savoir lannel ou la NEM et donc
satisfaisant nous avons été très
attentifs madame la ministre et prenons
maintenant actes du processus de
planification partant des communes qui a
été entérinée il se concrétise par la
définition de zone d'accélération pour
l'implantation d'énergie renouvelable il
a également été précisé que les communes
ne pourront définir des zones
d'exclusion des énergies renouvelables
qu'une fois les zones d'accélération
elles-mêmes définies et qu'elle soit
suffisamment nombreuses pour que les
objectifs de la PPE puissent être
atteints une mesure de bon sens qui
évitera des vétos arbitraires qui
étaient d'ailleurs rejeté par les
associations des lieux locaux néanmoins
le processus de planification n'est pas
suffisamment abouti certes les scottes
les pluies seront consultés mais la
proche territoriale permettrait une
meilleure acceptabilité des mix
énergétiques et meilleurs répartition de
la valeur nourrissons dans nous restons
dans un entre deux politiques plus que
nos stratégique un débat c'est un story
concernant la vie conforme à vie simple
des architectes des bâtiments de France
le consensus trouvait en CMP illustre
surtout le manque de moyens alloué au
service pour accompagner au mieux
l'implantation des projets en fonction
de la réalité de terrain d'autres points
du texte final sont plus contrastées sur
la grillevotaïsme nous avons été
constants pour défendre la nature
première du foncier agricole la
production alimentaire notre devoir
étant de protéger l'agriculteurs et
lutter contre les effets d'aubaine
visant à transformer notre modèle
agricole en devastes champs de panneaux
photovoltaïques la plupart des
arbitrages se décideront par décret et
nous serons attentifs à suivre leur mise
en oeuvre néanmoins la recherche d'un
modèle économique et environnemental
agricole mérite d'être travaillée pour
terminer nous déplorons la suppression
de la disposition introduite par
l'Assemblée nationale qui permettait
d'interdire aux producteurs de suspendre
à leur initiative leur contrat de
complément de rémunération avant leur
terme pour profiter seul au détriment de
la collectivité de l'envoler des prix de
l'énergie et donc des surplus de revenus
engrangés ce processus rend l’état
systématiquement perdant en le privant
de recettes finalement à l'issue de nos
débats ce texte va néanmoins dans le bon
sens même si des alentours des
interrogations demeurent à la fois dans
la mise en oeuvre des mesures mais
également dans les arbitrages qui seront
décidés par décret il est néanmoins
encore insuffisant voire trop complexe
sur le plan de la planification
territoriale
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables nous pourra se faire que
dans le cas de projets de territoire
cohérent permettant de répartition de la
valeur équilibrée et permettant à chacun
de prendre sa parole objective fixé je
vous remercie
on a encore un débat derrière donc si
vous pouviez respecter votre temps de
parole ce serait formidable et
maintenant nous allons entendre monsieur
Fabien gay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste pour 5
minutes
merci beaucoup
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues après les énergies
renouvelables début novembre l'énergie
nucléaire début janvier nous discutons à
nouveau suite à la commission mixte
paritaire des énergies renouvelables le
groupe communiste défend et nous l'avons
dit un mix énergétique équilibré avec
une part de nucléaire et une part
d'énergie renouvelable mais nous vous le
répétons il y a un problème de méthode
et d'ailleurs une commission mix
paritaire avait 18 amendements en séance
pardonnez-moi généralement vu ça et il y
a pas que des amendements de
coordination j'ai envie de chacune et
chacun à lire l'amendement 16 avant de
se prononcer sur le vote il aurait
d'ailleurs fallu privilégier une
discussion d'ensemble pour que nous
puissions justement traiter de cette
question du mix énergétique dans son
ensemble preuve que tout cela est fait
dans le désordre nous allons au bout
d'un long chemin législatif discuter du
plus en plus annuel pour la politique
énergétique qui arrivera cet été
cette segmentation des débats a au moins
une cohérence d'ensemble madame la
ministre dans aucun cas aucun cas vous
n'agissez pour que l'énergie sorte d'une
logique de marché ni pour qu'elle soit
vendues à des tarifs accessibles à
toutes et tous nous voyons bien où cela
nous mène l'électricité le gaz augmenter
de 15% au premier février et les tarifs
réglementés du casse disparaîtront en
juin prochain d'ailleurs toujours pas un
mot sur cette extinction madame la
ministre en pleine crise énergétique
êtes-vous prête pour livrer aux appétits
financiers les 5 millions de foyers qui
dépendent des tarifs réglementés du gaz
un jour il faudra nous donner votre
position pire je ne sais pas si cette
loi permettra l'accélération la
production d'énergie renouvelable mais
elle accélère à sans doute la
libéralisation du marché de l'énergie à
travers l'utilisation des PPA comme on
dit ou encore le partage de la valeur
qui vont se généraliser dans de
nombreuses
et intercommunalité tout cela est en
opposition totale avec le service public
de l'énergie que nous défendons ensuite
pas un mot sur qui développera ses
énergies renouvelables le public ou le
privé et puis si nous voulons accélérer
encore faut-il des travailleurs et
travailleurs formés des filières de
formation et des filières industriels
pour construire entretenir et démanteler
les panneaux photovoltaïques et les
pales des éoliennes ou concevez-vous
cette accélération comme une énième
dépendance face aux entreprises
chinoises et à leur savoir-faire là
encore pas un mot alors je note et nous
notons qu'il y a quelques avancées nous
voulons les souligner vous avez entendu
le besoin d'associer les communes dans
la définition des zones prioritaires est
propices à l'installation de sites de
production d'énergie renouvelables par
ailleurs plusieurs surfaces déjà
artificialisées comme les parkings
permettront la création de milliers de
mètres carrés de panneaux
photovoltaïques ce sera aussi sur le
toit des bâtiments non résidentiels et
au total on peut supposer que nous
doublerons notre capacité de production
d'ici 10 ans toutes ces dispositions se
feront pourtant au prix d'un
contournement du code de l'urbanisme du
code de l'environnement et en
contradiction avec les démarches de
concertation promues dans tous les
projets urbains que nous connaissons
dans nos communes sous prétexte de
rattraper un retard accumulé depuis des
années vous faites une croix sur des
dispositions essentielles protectrices
et utiles c'est notamment contre ces
régressions que nous nous sommes
mobilisés avec les collègues lors des
débats en séance il est paradoxal de
promouvoir des énergies dites
renouvelables censés être plus
respectueuse de l'environnement en les
actant au détriment des espaces naturels
forestiers littoraux le fait de limiter
le dialogue et les recours possibles
autour de ces projets nos fuira plus de
les possibilités suffisantes pour tenir
un débat public
utile et serait nous craignons ainsi
quand vous leur donniez quelques mois au
détriment de la concertation vous perdez
finalement plusieurs années avec des
oppositions cristallisées enfin il y a
un enjeu global l'urgence climatique et
l'absence de réponse pour laquelle la
France est régulièrement condamnée ne se
résoudra pas seulement par la croissance
de la production d'énergie renouvelable
il faudra aussi passer par la réduction
de la consommation d'énergie fossile que
ce projet de loi ne nous a pas permis
d’aborder c'est pourtant une aspiration
majeure de notre groupe qui doit passer
par la lutte contre les passoires
thermiques la promotion du transport
ferroviaire des mobilités douces ou
encore l'accompagnement de notre
agriculture c'est considérations sont
pourtant absents du texte tout comme la
question du maîtrise publique de
l'énergie en filigrane ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est plutôt que vous
souhaitez accélérer la libération du
secteur à l'heure où toute la crise que
nous vivons nous prouve qu'elle est
l'échec cuisant c'est pour toutes ces
raisons que nous nous abstiendrons
merci chers parfait
je vais donner la parole au président
Jean-François Longeot pour le groupe
Union centriste pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
mesdames la présidente madame la
ministre nous retrouvons aujourd'hui
pour examiner le fruit de la commission
mixte paritaire qui s'est réuni le 24
janvier dernier sur le projet de loi
relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable près
de trois mois après le début de son
examen je me félicite qu'un accord ait
été trouvé entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale sur ce texte texte
indispensable à la préservation de notre
souveraineté énergétique et à l'atteinte
de nos objectifs climatiques vous savez
la France fait skieur de mauvais élèves
dans le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables elle est le seul pays de
l'Union européenne ne pas avoir atteint
l'objectif qui lui est fixé à l'horizon
notre responsabilité était donc de
taille dans l'examen de ce projet de loi
notre commission c'est féliciter du
dépôt de ce projet de loi qui constitue
le premier texte intégralement consacré
au développement des énergies
renouvelables dans notre pays néanmoins
comme Didier Montlhéry et moi-même
l'avons exprimé de concerts lors de
l'examen en première lecture sa version
initiale nous a laissé sur notre fin
outre des oublis notamment s'agissant du
gaz et de la chaleur renouvelable nous
avions en particulier déploré de lacunes
un manque d'ambition simplificatrice
d'une part et le manque d'outils
destinés à favoriser la corsertation
locale d'autre part
nous avons donc abordé l'examen de ce
projet de loi avec une ambition claire
celle d'accélérer plus substantiellement
la réalisation des projets d'une part en
institant une démarche de planification
territoriale afin de favoriser une
meilleure approbation locale et d'autres
parts en simplifiant plus amplement les
procédures administratives applicables à
ces projets l'Assemblée nationale a
poursuivi le travail engagé par le Sénat
en confirmant nombre de nos ajouts comme
la création d'un fonds garanti destiné à
compenser une partie des pertes
financières subies par le porteur d'un
projet d'énergie renouvelable qui
résulterait d'une annulation par le juge
administratif d'une autorisation
administrative et l'institution d'un
référent préfectoral pour faciliter
l'instruction des demandes
d'autorisation et l'accompagnement des
porteurs de projets pour n'en citer que
deux
bien entendu des divergences de vues se
sont né en mains en ces jours entre nos
chambres elles ont donné lieu à de
riches échanges entre les rapporteurs de
l'Assemblée nationale et ceux du Sénat
en amont de la réunion de la commission
mixte paritaire ce dialogue
constructif a permis de trouver un
accord ou une rédaction de compromis sur
l'ensemble des dispositions restant en
discussion et je tiens à ce titre à
saluer l'engagement important et le
travail effectué par Didier mandeli je
remercie également nos collègues de la
commission des affaires économiques pour
leur contribution à ces travaux Patrick
Chauvet et Sophie prima l'esprit de
co-construction qui nous a animé à un
emploi douté contribué à l'issue positif
de cette CMP en définitive le projet de
loi qui vous est soumis est un texte de
progrès par rapport au texte initial qui
confortent de très nombreux apports
série sénatoriaux j'en citerai
quelques-uns à l'article premier la
pénalisation de plusieurs mesures de
simplification administrative et visant
l'instruction des projets de NR alors
l'article 3 le dispositif de
planification territoriale ascendante
voulue par le Sénat était confirmé en
CMP et les travaux de la CMP ont permis
de donner plus de corps aux zones
d'accélération pour les énergies
renouvelables qui seront identifiées
localement en y provenant des mesures de
simplification procédurale spécifique
par exemple l'encadrement d'un délai de
trois mois de la phase d'examen des
autorisations environnementales
l'article 5 visant à limiter les risques
contentieux portant sur des projets de
production d'énergie renouvelables a été
rétabli dans une rédaction rédaction
proche de celle du Sénat aux articles 11
bis et 11h introduits par notre
assemblée un compromis a été trouvé sur
la solarisation des bâtiments dont
résidentiels existants et neufs qui
permettra de développer des
installations solaires en toiture
enfin ce texte a permis d'avancer sur
l'agricoltaïsme ce donc je me réjouis
tout particulièrement était ayant été à
l'origine avec mon excellent collègue et
amis Jean-Pierre Moga de la réflexion
sur ce sujet dans notre assemblée tout
compromis à un prix et certains de nos
ajouts n'ont pas passé le cap de cette
navette parlementaire je pense par
exemple à l'attribution Conseil d'État
de la compétence pour statuer en premier
et en dernier ressort sur les litiges
concernant les projets d'installation de
gaz renouvelables ces bémols sont
toutefois marginaux regardent et
nombreuses dispositions plus
structurantes qui ont été confirmées
aussi je pense je ne pense pas faire
erreur en disant que l'équilibre final
auquel nous sommes parvenus fait
largement au travail honneur à notre
travail sénatorial il me reste donc à
vous remercier pour le travail accompli
et à vous donner rendez-vous pour la loi
de programmation quinquennale que nous
aurons à examiner courant 2023 je vous
remercie
si la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Cordier européen pour 5 minutes
également
madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur c'est un Didier
madame la Présidente de la Commission
monsieur le Président chers collègue 7
titres plus une centaine d'articles plus
de 100 pages heureusement qu'il
s'agissait de simplifier d'accélérer
le texte qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
au sortir de la CMP particulièrement
danse danse mais heureusement le manque
d'ambition que j'avais regretté en
discussion générale a été en partie
comblée cependant madame ministre pour
remplir vos objectifs que vous êtes fixé
il nous faudra attendre des textes
supplémentaires dont on sait qu'ils
mettent parfois beaucoup de temps à être
publié sans parler de la validation de
certaines cartographies régionales et
surtout les moyens budgétaires mobilisés
devront être considérables si l'on veut
donner un minimum de corps à ce texte
salut on est en moins d'entrer de jeu
l'instauration des zones d'accélération
disposition absente du texte initial et
que le travail parlementaire à
l'initiative du Sénat aura permis
d'introduire preuve qu'il en était de la
période nécessité de laisser au député
sénateurs le temps d'exercer leur
mission de législateur et d'encourager
leur force de proposition mais un peu de
temps une seconde lecture n'aurait pas
été de refus le Sénat n'a pas eu n'a pu
se prononcer sur les nombreux articles
introduits par l'Assemblée nationale
ces autres d'accélération permettront
nous l'espérons une réelle planification
et à rééquilibrage du déploiement des
parcs éoliens et solaires et replaceront
les territoires au centre de la décision
consultation concertation à vie conforme
trois procédures qui redonneront aux
élus leur rôle légitime de maîtrise de
leur emprise territoriale tout en jouant
la carte de la solidarité entre
collectivités la possibilité
d'introduire au sein des PLU ou des
scottes pour les communes soumises au
règlement d'urbanisme la définition de
zone d'exclusion pour l'implantation des
ENR conforte elle aussi le principe que
les élus locaux sont bien les mieux
placés pour organiser surtout valider
les aménagements les plus pertinents
pour leur territoire
je sais que certains représentants de
l'industrie des ENR ils voient une
complexification du processus et un
risque de retard mais s'agissant de la
transformation de nos collectivités la
concertation avec les élus et au-delà
avec les habitants ne peut pas être
sacrifiés c'est le contraire un gage de
réussite a-t-il personnel parce que j'y
suis attaché que je crois dans cette
énergie nouvelle je me félicite de
l'intégration des installations
d'hydrogène renouvelables et bas carbone
dans le corps du texte il en va de même
pour l'équilibre trouvé dans plusieurs
articles entre la volonté d'accélérer le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
et celles de préserver notre
biodiversité comme nos paysages
pertinentes également l'introduction de
l'obligation pour les entreprises de
plus de 250 salariés d'élaborer un plan
de valorisation du foncier en vue de
produire des ENR
regard des enjeux de notre conversion
énergétique il est juste que tout s'y
contribue y compris les entreprises
toujours à titre personnel je regrette
que les peuples étaient retenus la
proposition d'alléger les procédures
d'avis des ABS pour faciliter
l'implantation en ville des panneaux
solaires quand bien même il serait à
proximité de cyclasser Madame la
Ministre panneau noir sur toiture noire
il y a désormais plus d'espoir plutôt
que systématique être dans un périmètre
classé le choix aurait pu être plus
pragmatique la toiture en question
est-elle réellement visible depuis le
site classé sur le fond du texte et même
s'il mentionne désormais des ENR qui en
étaient absentes il va toujours pas
assez loin sur la globalité de l'action
amener pour créer un véritable
écosystème de la conversion bas carbone
depuis la formation jusqu'à la mise en
place d'une véritable filière
industrielle en passant par la
transformation de notre économie basée
encore trop massivement sur les énergies
fossiles au final nous sommes devant un
texte qui t'éloigne qui est loin de
faire l'unanimité les professionnels du
secteur des ENR le qualifie pour
certains de néfast
une accélération du moins un signe les
défenseurs de l'environnement le
contexte pour les risques qui
l'emportent pour nos paysages et la
préservation de la biodiversité les
associations d'habitants ne sont
absolument pas convaincus notamment
celle mobilisés contre l'éolien marin
seuls les élus locaux sembleraient
puisque conforter dans le responsabilité
ce qu'ils en conviendront réjouit les
sénateurs que nous sommes cependant
madame unis sur le verre étant plus qu'à
moitié remplie ce texte sera
majoritairement voté par notre groupe je
vous remercie
si chers collègues la parole est à
madame la Présidente Sophie prima pour
le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 la France
doit doubler sa production d'électricité
des carbonée cela suppose d'abord de
consolider de renouveler le parc
nucléaire mais également de développer
de façon extrêmement volontaire la
production des énergies renouvelables la
France faible d'une décennie
d'atermoiement est aujourd'hui à la
traîne à la fois dans le nucléaire mais
aussi dans les énergies renouvelables
l'objectif d'accélération qui sous-tend
ce projet de loi et donc partagé car
essentiel à notre souveraineté une fois
de plus laissez-moi regretter que nous
soyons obligés de légiférer dans le
désordre car oui bien sûr il aurait
fallu commencer par la loi de
programmation sur l'énergie mais plus
encore nous les ychons trop à l'aveugle
puisque seulement 15% des 112 articles
ont fait l'objet d'une étude d'impact
enfin et pour en finir avec les regrets
nous n'avons pas toujours les fichiers
ferrées sur les véritables en jeu le
texte initial était muet sur l'énergie
hydraulique il était muet sur les
collectivités territoriales qui
consacrent pourtant 5 milliards et demi
d'euros à la transition énergétique le
Sénat a corrigé le tir et nous avons
infléchi et enrichi le texte en premier
lieu ça a été dit plusieurs fois nous
avons associé les collectivités en
respectant leurs compétences leur
finance et en privilégiant une approche
décentralisée en matière de
planification il faut bien avoir
l'esprit que nous avons garanti aux
communes la maîtrise de la définition
des zones d'accélération et de la
réglementation urbanistique qui en
découle nous avons permis à l'ensemble
des communes de recourir au dispositifs
dit 3DS elles pourront ainsi réglementer
l'implantation des types d'énergie
renouvelables de toutes les énergies
renouvelables et même les exclure sous
conditions la vie des communes sera
enfin requis en cas d'implantation de
ces énergies en zone littorale alors oui
mes chers collègues la planification
demandera aux élus
les opérations d'autoconsommation qui
seront facilités pour l'électricité
renouvelable et instituée pour le biogaz
l'objectif de notre groupe a été de
faire en sorte que les collectivités
s'approprient la transition énergétique
est dispose des moyens de le faire en
second lieu nous avons garanti la
neutralité technologique entre les
différentes énergies et les différents
équipements c'est pourquoi nous avons
fait adopter des incitations pour trois
secteurs l'hydroélectricité le biogaz
l'hydrogène en troisième lieu nous avons
permis l'accélération des projets par la
simplification des normes par le
financement des actions et la résolution
des litiges enfin nous avons essayé de
combler quelques impensés du texte qui
sont aussi ceux en général de la
transition énergétique le premier c'est
l'emprise foncière de cette transition
et nous avons fait en effet prospérer la
proposition chère Jean-François Longeot
sur la gros voltaïsme adopté au Sénat
qui fera l'objet ainsi pour la première
fois d'une définition légale d'une
planification et d'une information
légale d'appel d'offres dédiée et de
souplesse urbanistique le second impensé
c'est bien sûr la dépendance minière de
cette transition car les énergies ne
renouvelables sont de très grosses
consommatrices de métaux critiques pour
tenir compte de cette consommation nous
avons appliqué un bilan carbone à
l'ensemble des projets d'électricité de
gaz et d'hydrogène renouvelable soutenu
par appel d'offres cela ne puisse pas ce
sujet qui est un sujet stratégique mais
nous ouvrons le débat si ce texte laisse
des regrets à certains d'entre nous au
sein du groupe les républicains
notamment sur l'éolien en mer nous
proposons son adoption car la
souveraineté énergétique de notre pays
est un enjeu majeur que nous ne serions
balayer du revers de la main le Sénat a
imprimé sa marque en territorialisant
les projets en remettant les élus locaux
au cœur du cœur de la stratégie au cœur
de cette stratégie nationale dont ils
seront les premiers acteurs je souhaite
remercier tous ceux avec qui nous ont
travaillé la commission du développement
durable les rapporteurs et le rapporteur
Chauvet pour la commission des affaires
économiques et vous remercier Madame la
Ministre du travail en commun réalisé
avec vous-même et vos services merci
beaucoup merci la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre mesdevielle pour le groupe les
indépendants dans 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
après certaines turbulences lors du
passage du texte à l'Assemblée nationale
la CMP a finalement produit un texte de
raison il nous paraît équilibré malgré
le nombre d'articles ajoutés et répond
ainsi à l'objectif principal fixé gagner
du temps
cependant je crois que c'est déterminant
le volet réglementaire tout aussi
essentiel que son pendant législatif
devra permettre rapidité et performance
je connais votre engagement madame la
ministre et je salue votre mobilisation
sur ce projet de loi dès sa préparation
je me félicite également du travail
fourni par les parlementaires des deux
assemblées les commissions précédentes
commissions rapporteur malgré quelques
incongruités que nous avons pu régler en
discutant et débattant nous positionne
n'était pas toujours alignée mais nous
avons largement enrichi le texte
pour le groupe les indépendants l'un des
principaux apports est bien sûr celui de
la grivevoltaïsme
lors de notre niche parlementaire du
vecteur dernier nous avons mis ce sujet
au débat grâce à une proposition de loi
qui a été largement adoptée et qui a été
inséré dans ce texte au moment de son
examen au Sénat j'avais déjà pu
m'exprimer en pointant la nécessité de
donner un cadre parfaitement défini à
cette activité
ainsi l'activité agricole restera
l'activité principale la production
d'énergie améliorera également notre mix
énergétique et fournira un revenu
supplémentaire agriculteurs sans faire
obstacle aux aides de la PAC
la précision de la définition de cette
activité éviter évitera les dérives que
l'absence de règles aurait pu favoriser
en ces temps de crise la grivoltaïsme
gauche toutes les cases du bon sens
un autre sujet qui me tient à coeur et
que je crois satisfait concerne la place
de nos collectivités territoriales et de
nos élus locaux dans le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables j'ai plaidé pour
trouver un consensus entre un droit de
veto excessif des mers et l'exigence de
développement rapide et efficace des
énergies bas carbone
leur voix compte ils doivent rester des
acteurs majeurs de notre transition
écologique ils connaissent parfaitement
leur territoire et la pertinence des
projets locaux les associés et le gage
d'une transition réussie je le mets ma
vie sur les documents d'urbanisme et
notamment ceux concernant les scottes
les objectifs de développement équilibré
du territoire ont été améliorés afin de
prendre en compte les nouvelles
installations de production et de
transport des énergies renouvelables
évoquer le transport d'énergie me permet
de revenir sur la question du
raccordement c'est un élément absolument
indispensable on peut installer toutes
les énergies renouvelables que l'on veut
si elles ne sont pas raccordées l'effet
est quand même restreint voir quasiment
nul
l'enjeu de l'intégration au réseau de
transport et de distribution et
principalement entre les mains du
gouvernement et des gestionnaires de
réseau
enfin je salue la possibilité sous
certaines conditions que le stockage
d'énergie puisse répondre à une raison
impérative d'amélioration de
l'intermittence de certaines énergies je
pense particulièrement aux stations de
transfert d'énergie par pompage dans le
même domaine le procédé powertogast nous
permettra aussi un autre mode de
stockage de l'énergie produite nous
pouvons cependant constater que notre
bouquet énergétique de votre être
absolument complétée par le nucléaire
qui fournit une électricité permanente
madame la ministre je conclurai mon
propos en regardant vers le futur
il est à la fois renouvelable et
nucléaire le mois dernier nous avons
examiné le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération des procédures liées à la
construction nouvelle installations
nucléaires
j'évoquais alors le caractère pilotable
de l'électricité produite en continu de
plus le nucléaire est et reste une
filière d'excellence française
si nous voulons amorcer sereinement ce
virage de modification de nos
consommations et de décarbonation nous
avons absolument besoin de fortement
augmenter notre potentiel de production
de production d'énergie bas carbone
les deux projets de loi d'accélération
ne sont que les prémices de nos
discussions sur le futur énergétique de
notre pays et ils étaient nécessaires vu
la situation d'urgence dans laquelle
nous a plongé l'invasion de l'Ukraine
nous compléterons nos dispositifs lors
des lois de programmation énergétique
pour travailler très précisément sur nos
futurs besoins et impulser les nouvelles
orientations nécessaires en attendant le
groupe Les Indépendants votera bien sûr
en faveur de ce projet de loi je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Ronan Dantec pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoires pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur les rapporteurs présidents et
présidente de commission tout avait très
bien commencé sur le principe tout
d'abord 7 ans après la promulgation de
la loi relative à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte de
Ségolène Royal l'État et le gouvernement
proposé enfin au Parlement une loi
consacrée au développement des énergies
renouvelables permettant enfin la France
de tenter de crédibiliser un scénario à
horizon 2035 de réduction de la part du
nucléaire sous les 50% scénario affiché
mais jamais encore décliné en politique
opérationnelle
tout c'était bien poursuivi et
évidemment il reste au Sénat une
certaine nostalgie des années Pompidou
d'un hexagone centralisé et un peu
refermé sur lui-même ou nos centrales
nucléaires suffisait presque avec les
barrages assuré nos besoins électriques
et seulement électriques comme on
pouvait un peu s'y attendre l'offensive
va donc bien eu lieu mais à échoué
fauché par quelque part d'éoliennes
soniques il s'est ainsi trouvé au Sénat
une majorité claire pour refuser les
deux mesures qui auraient tronçonné les
mâts des dix éoliennes le Sénat a ainsi
refusé l'éloignement des parcs éoliens
en mer à 40 km des côtes et rejeter
l'instauration d'un droit de veto des
mers sur les implantations une
responsabilité dont je le rappelle il
n'était pas demandeur mieux voir parfois
à notre plus grande surprise plusieurs
amendements importants du groupe
écologiste ont été adoptés sur la
planification régionale l'alourdissement
des pénalités pour défaut d'équipement
panneaux photovoltaïques
[Musique]
sur le fameux article 3 qui marquait la
volonté unanime du Sénat de mieux
associer les élus locaux l'équilibre
final trouvé équilibrant zone
d'accélération et d'exclusion les deux
allant de pair pouvaient paraître six
ans votre slogan était d'ailleurs
percutant il y a quelques minutes madame
la ministre mais la vie conforme des
mers sur deux des étapes qui émet ce
processus risque de le rendre au final
plutôt bloquant et ralentissant c'est ce
que craignent aujourd'hui de nombreux
professionnels du secteur
il ne s'agit pas pour autant d'ignorer
les avancées de ce texte l'évolution des
procédures pour Léonie en mer va
permettre de gagner un temps
significatif dans l'instruction des
dossiers l'ouverture des contrats de
long terme aux collectivités importantes
pour mobiliser l'épargne locale enfin et
nous y étions très attachés la création
d'un fond pour la biodiversité dans le
cadre d'une loi sur l'énergie constitue
en dépit des montants rabotés en CMP
également une évolution importante en
élargissant pour la première fois à
l'énergie et non plus seulement à l'eau
l'assise des financements pour la
biodiversité madame la ministre le
geckovaire de mana PANI vous remercie
sincèrement pour votre attention sur ce
point de plus et des moins donc et à
l'horizon surtout le retour du nucléaire
sur lequel le président et le
gouvernement multiplie les signaux en
parallèle à la discussion de ce projet
de loi il ne vous a évidemment pas
échappé madame la mise que la vie des
filières productrices d'énergie
renouvelable était quand même au final
mesuré quant à l'impact de cette loi sur
l'agrovoltaïsme ça a été dit avant moi
ou l'éolien terrestre par exemple aussi
dans ce contexte le vote du groupe
écologiste sera lui aussi mesuré nous
nous obtiendrons sur ce texte qui ne
suffira pas c'est une évidence à ce que
la France respecte ses objectifs de
développement des énergies renouvelables
telles que fixées par l'Union européenne
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues alors nous allons
passer au vote j'ai été saisie d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
les républicains sur le traite et la sur
le texte pardon élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire modifiée par
les amendements du Gouvernement il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
ainsi plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
suite donc nombre de votants 343 exprimé
313 pour 300 contre 13 c'est adopter
alors je vais suspendre
je suis suspendre quelques instants
pour permettre
au ministre de s'installer la séance est
suspendue quelques minutes